the fight between Carl weather's Apollo
Creed and Dolph lr's Ivan Drago and
Rocky 4 is truly brutal and what went
down behind the scenes was nearly as bad
according to Sylvester Stallone weathers
and lungren did not get along on set
when the two were in the ring lungren
had been too aggressive with weathers
causing weathers to storm offset while
yelling profanities at his co-star after
4 days during which production on the
movie stalled Stallone finally convinced
weathers to return but only if lungren
agreed to go easier in the ring in 2020
Yahoo entertainment spoke with lungren
about his onset prus with weather
lungren said I was a fighter a karate
champion from Europe and I think when
Carl showed up he was like I'm going to
have to fight this guy he seems like
he's the real thing I didn't dislike
anybody on that set but I think he got a
little scared of me then I had to kill
him of course lungren is probably
referring to what his character had to
do in the movie there but in retrospect
maybe weathers was smart to get out of
there